[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
this is the first episode
of "The Developer's
Show" in 2017.
Remember to come back
every week for the latest
and coolest developer
news from Google.
You can now start
building actions on Google
with the developer platform
for the Google Assistant.
It's super easy to get started.
Just head on over to the post
linked below for an intro video
and links.
Finding success
in global markets
means considering how
each market differs,
planning for high
quality localization,
and tailoring your activity
to the local audience.
This new "Going Global Playbook"
provides best practices
and tips with advice
from developers who've
successfully gone global.
Click through to the
posts to get your copy.
Grumpy is an experimental
Python runtime for Go.
It translates Python
code into Go programs,
and those transpiled
programs run seamlessly
within the Go Runtime.
If you've been struggling to get
concurrent workloads to perform
well in Python or CPython,
Grumpy may be for you.
Head on over to the
post for the code.
2017 is going to be a great year
for boosting your app quality.
Get started with some tips
on how Firebase can help you
with this post.
The Santa Tracker
app for Android
is a Google holiday tradition,
but a challenging one
to monitor and update.
See, it's live for a few
months each year, but about 90%
of the usage occurs in just two
weeks at the end of December.
Well, this year,
we used Firebase
to maintain a high
level of quality
without ever having
to republish the app.
All the details are on the post.
Our new Cloud
Architect Certification
is helpful to businesses
making the shift
into cloud infrastructure
and platform as a service.
To earn your certification,
you must successfully
pass our Cloud
Architect exam, which
we invite you to
take by January 18
to qualify for some
special benefits.
More details are on the post.
Google Cloud Platform for
Data Center Professionals
is a guide for customers
who are looking
to move to Google Cloud
Platform and are coming
from a non-cloud environment.
Migration of any size
can be challenging,
so we're happy to provide
this as a first part
of a new resource to
help you as you migrate.
We've also published a new
guide to help you with testing
and experimentation in AdWords.
It helps you understand
whether any proposed
changes to your account will
help you reach your business
goals.
Find the link to the post
along with all the others
in the description below.
Remember to subscribe and come
back every week for the latest
and coolest developer
news from Google.
Oh, and happy new year.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
If you can't wait until next
week for the next episode,
maybe catch up on some of our
previous episodes from 2016.
[MUSIC PLAYING]